[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
also
whatever whatever we want [ __ ]
my tongue is a lazy tongue
tiff is drunk welcome back
yay welcome back to jason chen
doesn't this feel like asian youtube
2008. like we're all about to do a show
and so does it feel like asian youtube
tiffany
yeah asian youtube am i even in this
video i don't know
you know what i think like oh we're the
asian youtubers
if rick was here everybody else is here
that art agent they're still asian to me
he's your boyfriend forever oh yeah
that's my favorite jk video
ever hey boyfriend that was my top one
and then whenever i talk about it asian
youtube era i always talk about like i'm
always like yeah and andrew garcia well
and
andrew's asian he's part of that circuit
part of that whole scene
the memories like even tori kelly i view
as asian youtubers
like she was part of that like asian
singing group it was a scene it was a
movement yeah at the in and out
always yeah always after the show oh man
good times bro
you miss them it was a fun it was like a
really
really fun time you know to be like in
your 20s and then getting booked and
flying out and just doing
art getting paid to like travel the
world and [ __ ] like we filled like
you know really big venues it was crazy
it was pretty fun
yeah it was wild and it was like a dream
now yeah
it feels like a different life yeah it's
only just a dream just only just a dream
but you still do shows like in china and
stuff right yeah what's that like i did
but not this year obviously because i
feel like all of the asian like college
shows or whatever like variety shows
like they died down
but i feel like you still i get them for
like specific
asian holidays um like chinese new
year's
or like normally like mid-autumn
festival i'd probably be somewhere
in china no like around here oh college
show still
college shows are still pretty lit oh i
mean they were before the you know
when we were still allowed to travel i i
liked i i started getting
hit up to do speaking engagements and
that was like my
favorite it's so easy huh yeah when i
didn't have to perform i didn't have to
like
put on a show literally i could just
like talk for an hour do a little uh
q a and i still could like get the bag
and just kind of talk
and at first i was like why i was like
are kids even gonna come but then i
realized that
all the kids that started watching me or
watched me when they were younger
they're all in college now so it's all
like my
some og supporters coming to just ask me
questions
yeah that's pretty cool they just want
to see you yeah pretty much sometimes
we're like a relic now yeah back then it
was like oh yeah we're like the same age
and then now it's like oh i used to
watch you when i was a kid
you got these like people come up to you
they're like bro started watching you
when i was in junior high
just graduated college man thanks for
your advice videos
holy [ __ ] looking past like you feeling
old when they say that i really do
appreciate those comments because i'm
just like
damn like you've been like a supporter
for so long and i
i don't know i really like it you don't
go like wait a minute
so you had nobody in your life and i was
the one that was giving you this kind of
insight and wisdom i feel [ __ ] sorry
for you man
you need to raise the bar there's so
much better [ __ ] online
well not when we started it was only us
bro and plus like
you got you gotta imagine a lot of these
asian kids that were writing to me for
like relationship advice they couldn't
talk to their parents about like sex oh
yeah i remember that
oh everybody was afraid to say dear
delegates
that's why we made ask the feels we'll
never forget with your [ __ ] nugget story
because ask the feels i was like i was
like man how come everybody's so ashamed
of like being sexual
and all that stuff and it would be kind
of cool if um we can talk openly
about problems and things and see that
it's all normal
like everybody goes through the same
[ __ ] and it was so funny because two of
the most common things was
is my dick big enough and my boyfriend
won't [ __ ] me it's always the same
yeah because you would think right like
everyone is like
you would think that the guy's libido
was always higher than the girls but we
had so many
messages is like yeah my boyfriend
doesn't [ __ ] me enough how do i get them
to [ __ ] me
i think i mean yeah you got to realize
you know girls are as horny as dudes
they just don't
they get shamed for it you know so they
don't know how to ask for it yeah
or if they want it too much then the
guy's like oh i'm not that horny yeah or
they think like or like you know a lot
of girls
they want to have sex on the first date
but then they have that whole like
oh if i give it up on the first day like
i'm you know they looked at it as a
whole or whatever you know i don't care
yeah you could care less i didn't care
yeah she [ __ ] on the first day and then
just stays with them forever that's
exactly
my my my style yeah yeah hell yeah
you know what changed my when i changed
my perspective but really helped
mold that for me is um on the outcast
album
on the love below there's a little
interlude where 100 3 000 he just like
smashed some chick
and he's like man she probably thinks
that i think she's some kind of hoe but
i don't care about giving up on the
first date that that just lets me know
she knows what she wants out of life and
i was like yeah
really i was like even as a kid yeah
you're right andre 3 000.
that's this child but if they what the
[ __ ] did it just change yeah i pulled it
up a little bit
it's kind of like ray j with his beanies
that moved every time it cut
if they're good doesn't that make you
immediately addicted and you want to
keep going
over why do you think i kept them for
something ah that's why
casey was supposed to be your whole face
and then you guys just stuck
exactly that was the first the first
whole face got failed because
instead of being a hoe you just be you
just stuck in the relationship uh you're
a bad
good dick yeah you did or you're just a
a whack groupie yeah you fall in love
right away
you should have waited and test out all
kinds i was trying to
and then you go back to him and such a
loyal ass [ __ ]
that's a good way to tell though is like
you get it on and
you go oh well it didn't work or like i
want to come back and try again i don't
know knowing what i know now and i i
[ __ ] around with this a lot and going
like man if i can go back
um i would have wanted to have hooked up
a lot more um
but i don't think i would yeah i don't
think i would i think
i think i have too many like like um
like things i have to check off before
i'm like attracted to a guy
yeah me too i would say casual is never
as good as like
you gotta know him a little bit yeah i
need really connected [ __ ]
i don't know man that's a pretty sweet
casual thing
yeah i mean everyone's different like
there's girls too that are like the
i don't think it's a male female thing i
think it's just a personality thing but
like friendship
[ __ ] is the best i think oh i can't
dude
ruin it no no no not like that like it's
it's you can't be long
time friends well you guys are [ __ ]
friendship [ __ ] it was so weird
it was so weird i was like i would tell
him i'm like i can't believe i'm [ __ ]
part this is weird like i really had to
look past it it was hard
we had those conversations in the middle
of section it was weird yes
like they'll be like this is so weird
but i'm like i know geo yeah like
because we wouldn't
that's like eating your [ __ ] this is so
weird i'll tell you what this is i did
not expect it to look like this let me
tell you
i really relate because of my last
relationship like we were actually
really close friends for a while and
same thing like
every time we'd kiss in the beginning
i'm like this is [ __ ] weird you're my
best friend
i take that back i don't think friends
should [ __ ] it's
a step above casual but it's a step
below romantic
friends with benefits right so like you
enjoy each other's company
you can't be good friends then i
wouldn't want to be acquaintances yeah i
think
i can [ __ ] acquaintance where i'm
like i i don't want you for long term
but i think you're attractive you have
like enough attractive qualities but i
don't want long
and they're cool to hang out with and
then you might catch feelings but it's
not the right time for you to
yeah i think that's pretty dope i think
yeah back when like
when it when i wasn't in like uh serious
relationships and i was just kind of
like you know having fun like homegirls
and stuff like one of
the the best um and easiest like
approaches would just be like oh yeah
hahaha like we're friends or whatever
but then you throw out a little joke
just to see how they react like oh yeah
yeah nah nah let me like
let me massage your booty hahaha i'm
just playing unless you're down it was
always like i'm just playing unless
you're doing that
i was waiting for that moment that's the
thing
but you can play it like a joke and
everybody knows test the waters yeah
it helps that you're already a funny guy
yeah not everyone can do that
yeah okay so what do the girls do
go ahead right well it's like if if
they're not
down then they we can all laugh or like
and i can just be like haha i'm just
playing but if if they're done
how do they respond when they are down
when they're all when they are down
it's like uh oh my god you're so bad
something like that how do you define
casual versus like
you both are going in for the same thing
so for example right like um in my
definition of casual
will be like unexpected one night stand
or like just
steamy as hell real quick and then you
went you didn't plan it
but then there's also the other form of
casual where you both are like yeah i
just want you physically
but i enjoy your company but it's it's
like friends with benefits right
um there's no future like deeper romance
or
like a relationship but there's those
two different kinds of casuals
and to me i think that the getting to
know a little bit
casual but with the intention of no
relationship
is way better than one night stance
i don't know i think planning is always
very important like you plan a [ __ ] that
day or just planning in life
what do you mean but you like what about
what about just hooking up like you go
and you see somebody
and then you like meet somebody and then
you go wow
what a steamy day and it happened
she would plan to maybe hook up yeah
and not and possibly be friends you know
what else is good at planning though
is like when you plan your finances
right exactly right
because this video is brought to you by
upstar baby
[Music]
during these tough times everyone is
looking for a way to feel more
financially secure if you're still
throwing money
every month at the high interest credit
card debt it's time you checked out
upstart the revolutionary online lending
platform
that knows you're more than just a
credit score now is the time to find out
how low your upstart rate can be to help
pay off high interest credit card debt
unlike other lenders and other women
upstart can reward you based on your
education and job history
in the form of a smarter rate but you
don't need a degree or diploma to apply
upstart lets you skip going to the bank
because it's completely online
they offer loans from 1 000 to 50
000 so many money so you can consolidate
your debt
into one easy fixed rate payment upstart
makes it fast and simple to check your
rate since it's just a soft pull
it won't affect your credit score the
hard pull happens if you accept your
rate and proceed with your application
the best part
if the loan is approved and accepted
most people get their funds
the very next business day
over 400 000 people have used upstart to
pay off credit cards to meet their
financial goals so free yourself from
high burden
of high interest credit card debt and
get back to using your money
your way with upstart so see why upstart
has a 4.9
out of 5 rating on trustpilot and hurry
up
to upstart.com record to find out how
low your upstart rate can be checking
your rate only takes a few minutes
that's upstart.com record your loan
amount will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application
not all applications will qualify for
the full
amount so jason i'm curious how did you
end up getting with your girl because as
far as i know
you were known as a picky guy and you
did not they're gonna say you can't get
girls
no i thought you should say player no
that you just didn't
like you were picky picky player
i was single for like three or four
years before
yeah oh you were yeah i remember you
being single for a long time wait i
never seen you with a girl
oh i have a friend who was it do you
remember i don't remember
oh i remember oh i do because we have
the same birthday
yeah and then that's when she would be
like happy birthday
for us and then that was funny and that
was it yeah
awesome you went from zero recognition
recollection
are you gonna answer tiff's question oh
yeah why i
i met her at a singing contest and then
she
actually asked for my number so she hit
on you but
she had a boyfriend at the time and it
was like
purely platonic and then she broke up
with him to be with you or five months
later
and came to shoot like a web series like
right next to where i live so we kind of
like and that's when i
had just gotten a puppy and she had a
puppy so like
that kind of like the doggies it just
seemed like kind of like faded out
the doggy style got you guys the doggy
style exactly
she bought a puppy just because she saw
you with one bro she planned that whole
thing
so now you you have those two dogs
there's like one is yours and one is
hers
technically that's cool is how long have
you guys been together now five
and a half years wow
in a while wow you guys do a lot of tick
tock videos together i like the one
where
um it's the one where she throws a high
heel and then the girl catches it she's
supposed to look sexy but then
it like missed because you walked into
the frame and then you're the one when
the girl closed
are you like a tic toc star now no i'm
i'm aspiring to be a tic toc
he's a real i haven't been able to get a
stardom on tick tock yes
do you have a tick tock me yeah i hope
you did because
you wouldn't have been able to download
it they blocked it last sunday or
something oh really
oh yeah no more new downloads of it is
that did that go through no that yeah
they didn't it's it's
they always say it and then something
happens and then it's okay again what if
it's all a lie
just so they can get more downloads
like remember when like six flags was
supposed to be closing yeah
yeah you're supposed to be going
bankrupt there's this whole thing it's
like this is the last summer you can go
to six flags
wait is it open right now yeah it looks
like it's not now no
not now they didn't shut down but they
didn't shut down but if you drive you
know
you want to echo when we go shooting
that one place you still see all the
roller coasters
they're not running but you see them i
went yeah when i first got back
i um i couldn't take it anymore because
i was alone in the house
and i was like go back from where europe
oh
during the quarantine time you just got
back were you bored in the house and i
was born in the house in the ballpark
and i was like really craving cinnamon
rolls right and i was like but the malls
are closed cause of the [ __ ] roanoke
how am i gonna get my cinnabon right
because you guys don't know i love
cinnamon rolls so i looked at a place
and um it was a pilot gas station
oh damn you were desperate yeah and i
drove over an hour
past magic mountain yeah to get
a cinnabon what do you mean a pilot gas
station
it was worth it dude worth it yeah it
was so worth it oh my god did you eat it
there you ate
at home i got two yeah one for tomorrow
and one so i could eat it hot yeah just
right there in the parking lot
and i was like so good
and then someone coughed and when i was
eating it and i was like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] i gotta move tables because he was
standing there and i was like the wind
might [ __ ] corona me but it was worth
it it was so worth it dude
but i remember magic mountain and it
wasn't running
it was the saddest day of my life i
thought i just saw a commercial where
they they have like a new roller coaster
or something or am i tripping
at six flex where are you watching
commercials on tv
usually you know you probably watching
rerun and [ __ ] goes the new
ninja ninja the new batman ride
[ __ ] the batman the riddler's revenge
and it's like oh [ __ ] they got a new
ride nah man i think there's a new ride
new fresh prince re-run and [ __ ] yeah
yeah google it
wait is it open because if it's open i'm
going do you remember when
uh you can you can go in with a soda can
yeah
oh yeah like on the back of a coke oh
yeah i remember those
when was this i never did it though six
flags is like the one day ticket is like
a season pass right west coast racers
west coast racers that was last year
december
20th 2019 so yeah right before the panda
you know how people used to do uh
youtube meetups at theme parks
yeah like meet and greets and [ __ ] and
then you would ride rides with all your
fans how fun
we never did it we never no we never did
it
but i remember a lot of people used to
do it like freddy w did it
uh that's it i don't know oh wow
they did a disney one and when i was at
theme parks i was trying to not tell
anybody that i was there because i was
you know
trying do you still do meetups do you do
like hey man i'm in this city come on
let's let's meet up
nah nah we did it i think the last time
i used to do that like yo what's good
i'm in seattle
oh the first time i ever did that i even
like
before i did it i did a little youtube
video like hey guys i'm going to be in
new york next week whatever i'll do a
meet and greet on
um do a little meet up on this day and
um and it was
crazy this is kind of when i was like
like like golden age of the youtube [ __ ]
and um and i did it and the police had
to like shut it down
because it was like so many people and
we needed like they were like you need a
permit and then we moved to another park
and then um and then security escorted
me out of the park because they were
like
they were like nah there's too many
people yeah that wouldn't happen now
what a flex
the last time we did it was in korea and
that's like eight years ago
we're at the park yeah because a bunch
of youtubers were there and they're like
oh it'll be fun if we just do a meet and
greet right now
and then i was like it's in korea though
like who's gonna come
and there's actually a lot of um fans
like that
that lived on the military base or just
english-speaking we announced in like
less than two hours too or something it
was like a quick
thing and then a bunch of people showed
up that's pretty cool it was really cool
man because i was surprised i was like
damn dude you guys speak english and it
was like
a white kid a black kid and like i was
like
what are you koreans doing no they'll be
like koreans and like
oh i'm speaking english like yeah i'm
from lakewood i'm like oh [ __ ]
okay crazy you know what actually we
could we would still get a crowd
nowadays if we had like some meetups
especially the free ones i feel like new
york how's your how's your guys's demo
in new york it's pretty big
second biggest same new york and toronto
is pretty up there yeah
texas too yeah you forget how many
[ __ ] asians are interested in
yeah my top three is like la new york
and
we're in australia where i think back in
the day i really liked meetups because
it was so fascinating and the people
were closer to my age right because
we're all college kids around there
so when you do a meetup it's almost like
you're meeting friends right
but now you do a meet up and it feels
very different very different i feel
like man i'm like they're like their
uncle
yeah i wanna i wanna do i would do a
meet up behind an activity i'll be like
let's go
surf or mountain bike or let's do an
event oh so you would do the theme park
thing
i would do that yeah because i get tired
at meeting greeks like i get bored
i was just gonna say i think we're not
doing meet and greets for free anymore
because they're so exhausting they're
more exhausted than shows dude
so if i if i'm doing meetups it's like
because i'm yeah i'm getting paid to be
there
you know because it's like it's like
it's work you know because it's you have
to have a very intimate
uh connection with with different people
like every five minutes
yeah and i don't have to be on and hype
and your energy has to be up exactly
for like three hours straight because i
don't want to do the picture go picture
go stuff
i like the conversation i think meeting
fans is cool
but four hours straight with high energy
is difficult
but if let's say it's like 30 minutes
and you can have some quality
conversations i think that's way better
because it doesn't feel like
a factory where there there's a [ __ ]
huge ass line you're like hey what's up
picture hey what's up picture
right and you're doing that over and
over like an assembly line i think that
it kind of kills the quality but then
everyone doesn't really have a chance to
see you all the time so it's like a
that's the only way they can but if you
can see them
and like do an adventure together let's
say like
i do a mountain biking meetup and then
10 people show up and we just ride
together
that's way more fun i have a question
for you guys um
when you guys are in public and you're
walking
and then a fan is like calling out and
saying
oh my gosh hi calling for your name and
stuff right and then you're saying hi
do you guys stop or have you ever
asked someone like do you want a picture
because i find that so
strange but i also feel weird walking
away without like
i did and i got like torn a new butthole
so i never did it again
what wow they're like nah this is this
is kind of like back in the
kind of golden days there was like a
couple
who was like kind of following me and
they were kind of like oh my gosh
why would they follow you we're at the
mall and then like so i turn around i go
hey
yeah i'm jason like would you like a
picture and then the guy
got like oh like
why do you think we want a picture with
you i was just like
oh i i don't like i was so speechless by
that because i meant well right but then
i think like the guy was like kind of
jealous
i don't know if he was jealous but it
was kind of like oh you're so arrogant
to assume that
i want a picture with he's definitely
insecure about it though but the same
thing happened when i went to
like youtube fan fest one year and like
i i met a i'm not gonna name him but i
was like
i was like i was just standing there
yeah and then like someone was asking
for picture next
next to me and he saw me he was like do
you want a picture i was like
sure so so i kind of get it so now i
kind of just i do my thing
and if they ask me i say yes but i know
i never like asked that
do you want a picture yeah i've never
asked either and then i feel
like there's been moments where
sometimes they'll be like
you can see it in their face like i want
to ask you for a picture but they're too
nervous or something and then they don't
and then i feel weird i'm like i know
what you want but i don't want to ask it
but you don't want to be that guy
oh you want a picture right yeah yeah
yeah yeah you want to be like me
i never asked him yeah i go if you want
it you ask for you get it
while they call me bart hey bart can i
get a picture
oh that happens all the time yeah
someone caught someone was like
he raphael right can i i was like
what no you cannot have a picture yo
there's people out there that take
pictures with
other human beings that they think is me
and the that that person will take a
picture and they'll tag you
oh and it does look like you though and
then they'll send it to me and we'll
and i'm like yo there is one guy that
legit looks like me
and they all think that it's me
hilarious
it's only for that guy but he's doing it
the funny thing is he's out there taking
pictures
he's like who's this joker and then you
get tweeted and someone's like i just
[ __ ]
at joe takawa and he was such a dick to
me
like i didn't [ __ ] that you want to have
the real thing instead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you